rango mada soir si j -ch le pouvoir
d'achat symboliquement les gilet jaune
de saulieu ont déposé un cercueil devant
la mairie ils étaient plus de 80 à
défiler dans les rues pour ce nouveau
jour de mobilisation comme aurélie
assistantes maternelles originaire de la
commune est aujourd'hui installée près
de dijon
moi qui ai des enfants on sait pas ce
qu'ils vont avoir plus tard ont ils en
auront rien si on se bat pas aujourd'hui
sur ce thème et je travaille depuis
l'âge de 15 ans 80 chauffeurs de cars
retraités demandeurs d'emploi petit
salaire à saulieu le revenu moyen est de
17 mille euros par an par habitant
contre vingt mille euros environ dans le
reste de l'hexagone
j'étais sur auxerre à 20 89 et je me
rends compte que même si on change de
dieu nous même si on change de
l'habitation ça devient de plus en plus
compliqué aussi bien pour les logements
au niveau du travail
marseillaise en choeur les gilet jaune
ont cette semaine interpeller les élus
locaux
reçus par le maire hier ce dernier dit
comprendre le mouvement après chose que
je dénonce c'est qu'on abandonne les
territoires c'est con recentralise tout
sur les métropoles
aujourd'hui ses 10 jan ce que je
souhaite aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
qu'on prenne conscience que dans nos
territoires il ya des gens il ya des
gens qui qui sont prêts à travailler il
ya des gens qui sont prêts à faire
beaucoup de choses à rester aussi dans
le milieu rural a fait revivre
d'améliorer notre milieu rural mobilisés
depuis le 17 novembre les gilet jaune de
saulieu tiennent un barrage filtrant
quotidien et entendent bien continuer le
mouvement jusqu'à noël